if you've been shopping for your
Thanksgiving meal you know the cost of
food is soaring the latest government
numbers show grocery prices are up more
than 12 percent from one year ago we
wanted to find out why Adriana Diaz went
on an expedition along the supply chain
to get to the bottom of it and spoke to
some people setting the prices
the 40 acres Fresh Market the greens are
usually the first to go look how dark
the green is it just looks so wonderful
here I had to get it so just the two
avocados Elizabeth the Buna small
business aims to sell affordable produce
on Chicago's West Side
you fresh food options your total is
going to be 35.26 since 2020 abuna has
raised her prices by at least 30 percent
at a time when food prices are up
everywhere we used to be able to get
blueberries two for five dollars and now
this is one pack is three dollars food
is costing a lot and it's very it's
noticeable when a customer says to you
this is too expensive I typically
explain it as I grocery shop just like
you do and it's it's hurting me too
there is no way I can offer this at the
same price that I did two years ago when
my labor expense has gone up my
Transportation expense has gone up and
the cost of goods has gone up those
goods come from her wholesaler the man
next to her Bob scaman who works for
strube's celery and vegetable company me
and him have a cucumber issue right now
there used to be a point where I could
sell cucumbers at 50 cents a pop and now
they're minimum a dollar Bob what's your
side of the Cucumber story we continue
to have bad weather in different growing
regions California was above 100 degrees
for almost two months straight when the
crops were being planted that are
supposed to be coming off for
Thanksgiving crops like what for
Thanksgiving green beans green beans are
ridiculous okay there is no reason why a
case of green beans should be costing me
fifty dollars once you get to fifty
dollars nobody needs green beans ever in
life again
labor is another Factor the minimum wage
went up in at least 25 States this year
even cardboard boxes are more expensive
due to a paper shortage two years ago
was a dollar ninety a box and now we're
paying you know 290 a bucks
remember these bright greens they come
from here go row fresh outside Chicago
owned by fifth generation farmer James
gobert fertilizer prices are up 100
fuels up 50 percent we need to pass it
on to the consumer but they can only you
know take so much
he says even twist ties cost more so
after his greens get packed rinsed
fooled he sells them to the wholesaler
Bob scaman for 14 a box up from eleven
dollars two years ago so the wholesaler
raises prices these are the greens going
to a buna's company for 16 a box
when we first started 40 acres Fresh
Market I could do greens at 69 cents a
bunch now at our markets we typically
sell greens at a dollar 25 a bunch what
would you say to somebody who's going to
a food market and raising their eyebrows
when they see prices have gone up I
would say they just need to think about
you know what goes into that there's a
lot of hands that touch the product and
all of our costs are up on every single
aspect so the cost has to go up for CBS
mornings Adriana Diaz Chicago